e
it's not an easy Journey when there many
choose from the easiest ones are the
ones where we
lose or need you to guide me I need your
light with me
[Music]
oh with
me I need you to guide me I need your
light with
me oh with
me it's not an easy Journey with these
roads to choose from the easiest ones
where we lose
all I need you to gu me I need your
light with me this road
long it goes
[Music]
ain't nothing
that look never getting fixed
har
who got your bloody
jacket
Jackie Omar
look who it
is hey Tina go do with theming pools man
early rise and grind
yeah you know what happen in
then so where's the food good to St you
got
begged Steve that
yeah did I not teach you anything you're
going to go and sort this yeah we go on
then I'm not waiting tilling
Christmas got you
bu
buy all one pick that up now I boss
relax
okay boss man said pick that
up H that's what I thought got the
bloody BFG by my side boys don't miss
with
me om how are you brother how you okay
be better boy stop pissing around in my
shop
one thank
you
yeah on the house got a lot to deal with
today
eh look at pick up your books
man one down near
me you're going to need this if you want
to come to my
class
thanks here we
go so you got a new
what about you and ala
though don't worry about
that I believe the first B re which
means you should be making your way to
your
classes so I suggest you stop behaving
like wild animals and get a move on
now CU I'm a ballb sir of
course at the end of the school year
has anyone read
this let me say it clearer
put your hands up if you've read this
book
sha
salmon
Aon and
Idris stand up please
gu out what I thought I was the one with
the hearing problems I said get out
why because you didn't do the readings
for this class so this class will be
useless to you and more importantly
you're going to be useless to this class
come on man it was a summer I'm not
going to spend my whole holidays wining
this dumb book so dumb man none of our
other teachers give a if you read the
book or not that's them and you watch
your mouth you're more than welcome to
come to my class when you've bothered to
read the book but for now I only want
the students who have actually read the
book to be in this class loud this man
where' you expect us to go cuz if Mr
Stones go to the student library and
make it start there or you can go out
and waste your time but you're not going
to waste my time on time with the
students here so that's it get out
now you forgot something
good morning a
12 in googi Wong is a Kenyan author
who's written the book that you've all
read but also written a groundbreaking
series of essays called decolonizing the
mind but how can a mind even be
colonized you guys know what
colonization is right
is it when a bunch of white people took
over African in that yeah it's a little
bit more complicated than that like Jay
said it's a bunch of white people you
know taking over Africa but where does
the Mind actually come into
this yeah I I I guess there's more to
colonization than most people think it's
more than taking over land or people
it's a state of mind it's a an
ideological takeover that influences how
the colonizer or the colonized think
nice that's
enough Shaw stalking your crush online
can wait what did you think of the novel
uh yeah great 10 out of 10
look there's no point being shy here
okay this is one of the few places on
Earth where your opinion is not only
welcomed but it matters have you ever
questioned why you have this seemingly
occurring indifference to the cultural
practices of people for example in
Africa do you not think for example that
if we were to take our cultural
practices the things that we find normal
to those people that they would find us
kind of weird true true
but I kind of relate to Wy you know he's
in between the tradition and the
West it's actually the first time I've
read a book where I could relate to the
main
character like I want to go to school
and that but all we learn about is this
white man did this this white man
invented that and then when we learn
about our people
Is Us in
Chains us fighting Against
Racism like come on we can do more than
that and I don't
know I feel like I'm too black for white
people and too white for my
people so dumb man nah bro I think we're
dumb what are you even talking about
bro I mean come on bro we can't even
read our teacher is kind of bad you know
no seriously he kicked us out like it
was nothing yeah probably because he's
too lazy to do his job so you are we
going to read
this hey Dr where's your book at where
it belongs up your ass
right this game man n bro I Dash in the
bin right in front of
Fe and what exactly are you boys doing
here wait wait wait wait hold on ain't
this the
library and what about your English
literature class sir it's not our fault
our teacher just threw us out cuz we
didn't read some
book
really right well continue reading the
works of uh
and Googy way
[Music]
thong and I can't tell you how grateful
I am to the thousands of you that turned
up in support of us and in defiance of
this backwards ideology that's dead set
on ruining this great country of our and
for those that did turn up I will say
this our movement is growing stronger
our voices are growing louder there are
more afternoon Mark
Omar how was your first lesson with the
year 12
students was good
really then why did I see several of
your students loitering around the
school I said up to the library cuz they
didn't read noquet
text why on Earth did you do that cuz I
want them to gain as much as they can
from the class they can't do that if
they haven't read the required text
listen Omar although I guess that in
itself proves to be a difficult task for
you your job is to come into this school
stand up in front of a class and teach
you're not here to bring your own rules
or life lessons for the boys you are
paid simply to turn up and teach who
cares if they haven't read the bloody
book that's their problem
stop making it
yours oh and um well done for dressing
adequately this
year except you may want to lose the
beard makes you look a bit like
a
caveman with backwards
ideology an absolute PRI it was my guy
how you doing bro you good
J what going on here we will not idly
stand by and watch this happen I bet
someone would love this guy I don't even
know how this is allowed on YouTube man
I thought it' be done for like hate
speech or
something oh man what what's
funny you know Colin
he's bagged himself a sister no this guy
I don't even believe is dating anyone L
on a
[Music]
black him don't allow that right
now that's it up
[Music]
that's that's enough man everyone better
get home right
now man don't even think about it and
that go
bro you m you stupid
yeah that's it I get it trust me I
do I Pi off
then let's leave man just's leave come
on just go
[Music]
interest in
it have a
seat don't mind I have so much to be
right now so I'm just I ain't asking y
sit down
lovely Ain
it yeah
sure was too long ago this was a war
zone cuz of me like it is
today
peaceful under
control you know what I mean
look if you don't mind I have somewhere
to be right now now your
brother he's right is it he's in
prison what's he
saying you ain't saying
much listen digs I know my brother it's
not a snitch
okay you know what
I've got a little
Adis come it's time to
go I got to go yet so
my what are you doing
here he's no good you got to stay away
from that guy man you forgot this book
you're lucky it was the first period of
the first day otherwise you would have
found us in a bin that you threw it in
[Music]
allb ald
ariet turn that TV off for a
second what
what you mean b don't you hear
that Bloody again is
it Mom you can't say that that's so
racist well no no it's not also he's not
Pakistani he's Arab I don't know they're
all the bloody same to me AR they no
it's not the
same did you hear
that now this is ridiculous
he's got a lovely singing
voice Omar open the Bry do now I know
you're in
there
what what is of all that singing and
chanting you keep doing in there what
you mean
praying I really couldn't care less what
it is I can hear your Islamic songs from
my bedroom how you expect me to relax so
you don't find it a little bit relaxing
you're disturbing the piece what
flipping piece of you talking about
Jackie well at least I understand what
that music means only God knows what
you're going on about in
there well it's a lack of understanding
is the
problem here you
go there now you understand it's kind of
like lyrics might night Jackie
oh J
yeah why you always asking questions bro
bro I've done this
before but if the feds come I'm
gone you hear me
bro n so what are we doing do we need to
do this of course bro
hey this guy's a
snake yeah I get that
still so what we doing
then at 11 he's getting his
stash we go to his yard and we teach him
a
lesson you're 100% sure he's going to be
there at 11 yeah
y why you always asking questions
bro you're moving
shook blood why are you getting rof for
you're in my house watch your mouth bro
I ain't here for you you chat to your
boy
man cat your boy who you getting rude to
blood
right
ohar anon's here cuz I told him to be he
owes
me he's going to be on
job I need you to be on
job listen to your boy
bro after tonight I don't owe you sh
we're done when I say you're
done don't you forget that
you got my
back have you got my
back yeah yeah I've got you still all
right let's
move
[Music]
e for
ready be two it's okay I love you baby
[Music]
get backing s
oh my God
[Music]
good
morning all right guys well you know the
drill who has read the
book all right well I like to see
progress yes I do um what
recie I promise you we'll read it by the
end of the day yeah man I don't know
what happens next with Waki and he's
school and all that he man no spoilers
shut up actually kind of like too you
know all right guys look stop begging me
all right you can stay this week but
next week you guys all have to read the
book all
right he's right here
wait you one
ss actually we're here for you
what Omar aad you under arrest for
suspicion of inciting terrorist acts you
don't have to say anything anything
make sure you guys read that book
[Music]
up oh